today of our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling this person her
name is
evie quang she works for the toronto
star
she was recently horribly offended by
some of the offerings at a pop-up broth
bar
inside of an athletic apparel store in
toronto of course many questions are
immediately raised about
why there's such a thing as a broth bar
and what that is exactly and
why it's inside of an athletic apparel
store and how any human could possibly
manage to be offended by broth
we may be able to answer some of those
questions in due course
as we proceed but first uh to evie
quang's tweets
she says there's a whole this is a long
tweet thread
as she goes on about it she says a white
owned trendy spot on osinton
is selling bone broth across from golden
turtle pho
also sexualizing jerk sauce and pho hot
sauce
and making super food dumplings for
profit
y'all i'm sick the cultures they are
taking from literally fight
daily for legitimacy the wellness
cleansing of the food
the lack of historical understanding and
the number of followers is alarming
i'm not trying to knock small businesses
and it is china by the way t-r-y-n-a
i'm not trying to knock small businesses
but
damn this one hurt i legit threw out my
chinese food lunches because white kids
would make fun of it all day
i bought into pizza day and dry ass
turkey burgers
so did so did many others and now you're
taking our culture and selling it
and people think it's legit damn it took
hella unlearning and relearning to love
my identity to get over that
don't come at me with organic grass-fed
immunity dumplings
it's zhao long bao i have no idea if i
pronounce that correctly surely if i did
not i am racist
um anyway she continues and while you're
here
support your local chinatown little
india little jamaica little tibet
korea town j-town and spots our aunties
and uncles opened
uh moving here to support their families
know that they've had to assimilate too
okay a lot of pride that was hard first
of all this is someone who works in the
media this is i guess a journalist
or something and that's how she writes
words like china
hella that's a problem but to translate
quang is
upset that this business is is selling a
few traditionally asian food products
somehow the existence of bone broth
cooked by someone who is not asian
has caused her to flash back to some
teasing she received in grade school
and because she has this weird emotional
association between
broth and bullying she believes that the
business
that produced the broth should be
destroyed it is after all cultural
appropriation
she says now something tells me and i
could be wrong
but i don't think i am something tells
me that miss quang
has never once complained about
restaurants run by asians
selling hamburgers or pizza and that's a
problem because
if we're going to play this game then it
must be played consistently and equally
it never is you never hear anyone
complain about non-white people
selling products that quote belong to
white people
which objectively speaking in a vacuum
is fine because nothing
belongs to white people as a group but
also
nothing belongs to any other group or
race or ethnicity or culture
as a group asians don't own broth
they don't own asian any asian food i
got news for you
individual items of food can be owned
but entire types of food cannot be owned
ihop
owns the pancakes it makes but who owns
pancakes in general
what group lays claim to the concept of
pancakes
answer none no group pancakes are the
property of the whole human race
and what a glorious thing that is and
guess what
what we call asian food is also the
property of the whole human race
anyone can make it anyone can eat it
anyone can sell it so evie kwong
you don't own asian food i own it just
as much as you do
guess what i am just as much as you
allowed to make it sell it eat it
i have just as much of a claim to it as
you do
that's the way it goes in fact the
cultural appropriation charge is never
as absurd as it is
in relation to cuisine because cuisine
especially cannot be owned by any group
of people
as there's probably no dish you could
possibly name which originates entirely
with one group and has remained
unchanged and uninfluenced for centuries
there may be some dishes like that but
they're few and far between
almost all foods and dishes are a fusion
of different influences and have changed
and been adapted and adopted over time
i'm no historian of pho but as far as
i'm aware
pha itself has very heavy french
influences
this is a fact overlooked by miss quang
these kinds of facts
are always overlooked by the people who
rail against cultural
appropriation now i have to add one
other thing
it's not just evie kwang getting
canceled tonight i must also cancel the
business
that she herself cancelled i'm afraid i
have to jump in with the pitchfork mob
but only because the business caved to
the pitchfork mob
you know after the outrage sparked by um
quang's psychotic tweets
the business called ripe nutrition
posted on instagram
the following message from its founder
this is what they said
over the course of the past 48 hours it
has come to my attention as the founder
of ripe nutrition
that i've made some mistakes big ones it
was important to me to take a moment to
collect my thoughts and decide how to
best address this situation
first i want to thank each and every
person who took the time to bring this
to my attention
something that i now realize should have
never been their burden to bear
is not the responsibility of people of
color to educate me a white woman
on why cultural appropriation isn't
acceptable the responsibility is mine
and mine alone
anyone who has spoken out about this
should never have had to do this work
and i apologize for my insensitivity
and ignorance as the founder of ripe
nutrition
oh dear god um we should note that
in spite of this groveling apology the
business was still kicked out of its
location in the apparel store so it was
still shut down
this is the way it always goes of course
the apologies never
make a difference they never have the
effect that the apologizer hopes for and
intends
never it doesn't matter they're not
going to go any easier on you just
because you apologize
and that's why everyone must stop
apologizing i'm at the point
where people who do apologize lose all
sympathy from me if you're going to cave
and kowtow and prostrate yourself
at the behest of these lunatics that i
am not going to defend you
why should i bother defending your
dignity and honor if you're just gonna
set it on fire willingly anyway
i mean burden to bear the owner of this
company actually just said
that her broth was somehow an emotional
burden
that some in the public had to bear as
if there were people up
late at night tossing and turning
distraught because some white lady was
selling broth in an apparel store in
toronto
if any such person actually exists which
i doubt
if there's if there's actually any
person who is at all traumatized
by this broth then they are mentally ill
and should be committed to an asylum
anyone who has ever felt any kind of
authentic distress
because the quote wrong race of person
was cooking a certain food
is not only a bigot but a lunatic
and that's exactly what you should say
to them when they try to cancel you
these lunatic bigots will never stop
we'll never slow down so long as there
are limp
spineless jellyfish-like creatures
floating around there
out there such as the owner of ripe
nutrition who can so easily be
manipulated and dominated
have some damn self-respect grow a spine
stand up for yourself you know
how about issuing a statement on your
little instagram account saying hey
guess what i'm not sorry it's broth
get over it you you insane babies
get over yourself how about that for a
statement
so everyone who complains about cultural
appropriation is canceled
and everyone who emboldens and
encourages and validates the complainers
is also cancelled cancelled cancelled
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content